- [Voiceover] Given all
of the recent talk about
the United Kingdom deciding
to leave the European Union,
often referred to as Brexit,
short for British exit
from the European Union.
I thought it would be
interesting to do a primer on
what exactly is the European Union?
This is gonna be a high
level primer, the topic can
get quite complex, quite fast.
But to understand what the
European Union even is,
I will draw a little lines
to represent the spectrum
of, I guess you could say
national organizations,
or organizations of nations.
So at this end right over here, I'll draw,
this is a trade block, this
is when a group of nations
get together and say,
"Hey, let's have free trade
"between our countries".
Let's make it, if we make
something in one country,
we want to sell in the next,
that there's no tariff on them.
And it might include things
like, it's easy to move money
between one country to another,
and sometimes it will even
include it's easy to move
people between one country to
another, and a good
example of a trade block,
especially from a North
American point-of-view is NAFTA,
North American Free Trade Agreement.
This is the United States,
Mexico, and Canada having
a free trade agreement.
You make something in
one of those countries,
you want to sell it in the
other one, you don't have to
have, you don't have any
tariffs, it makes it reasonably
easy to transport goods
from one country to another.
There's even some provisions
around investments
and the movement of people.
Why would a country ant to do this?
There's many economic
arguments and theories that it
increases the prosperities
of all of the parties.
Now some folks will disagree
with that, but they might
say on average it might, but
there's definitely going to be
some losers in different
countries depending on which
industries go where, but
that's the rational for why
free trade agreements exist.
That it would increase the
economic growth of all involved
and it'll make them all
be able to participate in
a larger economic shared market.
Now at this side of the spectrum,
I'm gonna talk about when
states get really close to
each other to really form
a meta-state, to really
form a country made up of
those states, and I will
call this a federation.
Maybe the most famous
federation, especially from
an American point-of-view
would be the United States.
United States of America,
it is made up of 50 state.
It literally stands for
United States of America.
Those 50 states have become
so integrated that they act as
one country, they act as one
nation, they act as one people.
Each of those states,
they are semi-autonomous,
they do have their own
governor, their own legislator,
their own courts their
own laws, but they...
There's also a federal government,
there's a federal army,
federal courts, there's a president,
there is a federal legislature.
They are so integrated
as to be one country.
Now in between you'll
sometimes hear words like
confederation, or confederacy, con-fed,
confederation.
And this is more of a lose
term, there's not a strict,
this is a confederation, or
that is not a confederation,
but it's generally viewed
as looser than federation.
That the states, or the
countries that are members
of a confederation can opt-in or opt-out.
That they might be
integrated in some ways,
and not integrated in other ways.
When we think about the
European Union, which involves,
which for sure involves
aspects of a trade block.
It has free trade, it involves free trade
between its members.
It talks about the movement of people,
so free, movement.
But it goes further than
a traditional trade block,
it goes further than something like NAFTA.
It has, in Brussels, it
has rotating leadership,
it has regulations and laws
that often apply to things
like free trade, and free
movement, but it can also apply
to things outside of that.
There's even some integration
between militaries,
or I guess at minimum you
could say cooperation.
Each of the members have their
own military, and they are
independent states in there
own right, but there is more
integration than you would
see in something like NAFTA.
So the European Union, I would
put it some place in this
spectrum right over here, and
depending on whom you talk
to you will get different
options, and different people
will debate, some people
say, "It's more about trade,
"and having a large shared
common market, and maybe being
"able to have a little
more clout on the world,
"even from a foreign
policy point-of-view."
While some people will say,
"No, it seems to be moving
"in this direction where
it's becoming a tighter
"confederation of some kind,
albeit with still a lot of
"independence from each
of the member states."
And the people who think it's
more on the right hand side,
they'll point things like,
look its got its own flag.
It's got it's own anthem,
you have some military,
more than cooperation, you
even have some integration.
The trend seems to be
moving from left to right.
It's not only is it about
trade, it's also about currency.
That's where I'm going to
introduce this other concept,
called the Eurozone, which
is often confused with
the European Union, that's
because there's a lot of overlap
between the two.
The Eurozone is a subset of the
European Union that uses the
same currency, and then that
currency is called the Euro.
This is about currency, and
this is, about the Euro.
Once again, this would
move it a little bit more
to the right, not only
do you have free trade,
and free movement of people,
and you have some regulations.
And of course the member
states have representation
in determining what those regulations are,
but you also have most of the
European Union has a shared
currency, which of course
facilitates free trade and free
movement, but this is more
than what you see in NAFTA.
Mexico, the United States
and Canada do not have
a shared currency.
What this map shows us is both the total,
the European Union, but it
also shows that it's not
exactly the same thing as the Eurozone.
Everything we see in blue
and this pink color combined,
that is the European Union.
The difference between
the blue and the pink,
is that the blue are European
members that also use
the Euro as their currency,
so they are members of
the Eurozone, so Spain, and
France, and Germany and Italy,
and the Republic of Ireland.
The are members of both the
European Union and the Eurozone.
While countries like the
United Kingdom, and Denmark,
and Sweden, and Poland, and
I could keep going on and on.
They do not currently have
the Euro as their currency.
They have their own currency,
they have their own central banks.
The UK, which is where we
started this conversation,
they have the British Pound sterling.
Now in terms of whether, or
how, or whether they're gonna
move to the Euro, it's different
from country to country.
Countries like,
countries like the UK and
Denmark have official opt-outs.
They've never had any intention,
they've opt-outs of going
to the Euro.
Countries like Sweden, it's
not as official, but it doesn't
look like they have any
intention of going to the Euro,
while other countries, it's
just a matter of time before
they do go to the Euro, and
it's more of them meeting
certain economic and fiscal
thresholds so that they
can enter into the Eurozone.
Once again, why would you want to become
part of the Eurozone?
If you're a country
with a smaller economy,
or a smaller currency,
or less stable currency,
you say, "Well, I could become
part of a larger economic
"zone, I'm already part of
free trade and all that,
"but the currency makes
it even a stronger thing."
Why would you not want to do it?
Well you say, "I have a strong
enough current, I don't want
"to give monetary policy
to folks in Frankfurt."
Once again, good people can
argue very good arguments
on either side of that.
When you look at this map
here, you might also notice
that Kosovo and Montenegro
are colored in in this
little pink color, and
this is interesting because
they are not members of the
European Union, but they have
decided to use the Euro as
their official currency anyway.
So they're not even official
members of the Eurozone,
but they still use the Euro.
So that's why they get their
own special color here.
So if we go back to Brexit,
if we go back to the
United Kingdom leaving, what
are the implications here?
Well, the first clear implication
is that their currency
is not going to change, and the
future of their currency is,
is not going to change.
They were never planning,
they don't use the Euro,
and they were never planning
on going to the Euro.
And so, they are using the
Pound sterling, and they will
continue to use the Pound sterling.
That's kind of a no-brainer
and the Brexit doesn't
impact that.
Same currency.
They're using the Pound
regardless of which way the
Brexit vote went.
What the Brexit vote does
by taking them out of the
European Union, is it puts
these things in question,
things like free trade and free movement,
and what regulations they
will adopt or not adopt.
It doesn't mean that
there won't be free trade,
or there won't be free
movement, or that regulations
will change dramatically.
It also doesn't mean that
that's not going to happen.
What it means is it's all going
to be called into question.
These are now going to have
to be separate negotiations
between the United Kingdom
and the rest of the European Union.